it was my dream to do action movies but
specifically Mission Impossible because
I think it's the best of this genre you
know it's more than just an action movie
I think it's art you know and the level
of excellence in in everything in these
movies is just you know it's just
mind-blowing so years prior uh Mission
Impossible even before getting cast in
gardens or a Galaxy Vol 2 I started
training martial arts so someone called
Jessa novello taught me how to cake how
to punch uh how to do stunts how to do
that on camera and all the tricks you
know it takes years to be good at
something to be better you know so
you're always learning I'm still
learning now but
um back then I was training and even
sometimes in my schedule I would write
Mission Impossible in my phone instead
of writing martial arts training or
stunts manifesting it was manifesting
the whole time it was like one day I
maybe I get to do a fighting with Tom
who knows he's ready and you did